les premières informations vol d'un
avion se soit précipité contre le world
trade center une carrément entré à
l'intérieur de l'immeuble tragédie qui
vient de survenir dans la ville de new
york on voit le deuxième appareil qui va
aller coucher
la deuxième tours du world trade center
lucien bouchard a expliqué pourquoi il
démissionne de ses postes de premier
ministre et de chef du parti québécois
le départ précipité de lucien bouchard
plonge évidemment le parti québécois
dans un bouleversement absolument
inattendu
toutes les personnes arrêtées vont être
amenés dans une aile spéciale de la
prison de bordeaux
boucher est l'un des quatre accusés qui
a été amené au palais de justice le
procès fleuve qui réunira des dizaine
d'accusés devrait se tenir dans un
nouveau palais de justice qui serait
relié à la prison de bordeaux
il était passé minuit à belgrade quand
des unités spéciales de la police
yougoslave ont pris d'assaut la
résidence de l'ancien président
milosevic
vous avez vous un premier bilan de ce
qui s'est passé cet après midi oui ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que depuis
le début du sommet le bilan officiel
fait état de 57 manifestants blessés il
ya énormément de bruit
daniel actuellement ses bouddhas de
bamiyan chef-d'oeuvre de l'art
bouddhique préislamique sculpté il y à
plus de 1500 ans sont peut-être redevenu
poussière nous allons faire le point sur
l'atterrissage d'urgence d'un airbus
a330 de la compagnie canadienne air
transat ce matin à 2h46 au large des
açores près du portugal
on a préparé l'arrivée imminente de cet
avion lors
c'est magnifique le spectacle est
renversant ce sont les premières paroles
de prayssac fils lorsqu'il est sorti
dans la soute de denver pour commencer
une marche de 7h10 dans l'espace